trois allez deux un
[Applaudissements]
qui est-ce ce n'est rien oh mec c'est Pete oh
mon Dieu j'ai trouvé ça assez drôle
tu es à Salem ils ne nous ont pas appris toute
notre histoire
certaines histoires se sont perdues en cours de route
peut-être que s'ils  nous avait appris tout ce
qui s'était passé
mon frère aurait laissé ce couteau
là où il l'a trouvé Je
jouerai je n'arrêterai pas
tu sais ce que je pense que nous devrions faire
maintenant aller à la fête allez allons-y
si tu joues avec moi alors je  Je te laisserai aller
à ta fête et je n'appellerai pas maman, ok
Joe,
à quel jeu veux-tu jouer avec la
caméra, nous dirons tous joue,
je n'arrêterai pas,
dis-moi un démon, suis-je
Marcus
étranger,
Marcus,
comment es-tu prêt à  joue à cache-cache
Marcus pourquoi as-tu ce couteau au revoir
pourquoi tu fais ça
[Musique]
continue ce n'est pas lui c'est le couteau que tu as
trouvé
hé mon pote tu es juste en train de nous embêter, n'est-ce pas, que diriez-vous
de quelque chose
qui ne se termine que quand il gagne
quoi  si nous gagnons, il n'y a qu'une seule façon de le savoir,
je jouerai, j'y
jouerai, je n'arrêterai pas, je
vais jouer, jouons à
un nouveau jeu
étranger